I would say that I began I didn't really
know what philanthropy was until i
actually had access to some dollars to
give away and that was after the public
offering of priceline and when that
happened Betsy and I were fortunate
enough to have some wealth and we
realized that we wanted to give back and
so we started studying philanthropy and
started studying great families and what
they were doing and that was back in
about two thousand and you and Betsy and
it was so wonderful to meet your lovely
wife that's who is also here with us the
north in our studio studio and so Thank
You Betsy for for being here when you
came into wealth did that pose a
challenge with in in terms of what you
were going to do with it in discussing
this with Betsy and your family and how
old work your kids at that time well
those are such great questions there I
believe our kids were probably eight and
ten roughly at that time and it posed a
lot of questions when you work for a
private company and the company goes
public and IPO going public means lots
of things become public and so we were
part of that wave the first wave of
Internet companies and so it was very
overwhelming to us to figure out we knew
that we wanted to give back to the world
we knew we wanted to focus on
environmental issues because we met in
forestry College as undergrads and
always had a passion for the environment
and so we knew that that's what our
focus was going to be but we had no idea
of what it meant to give money away I
think prior to the year 2000 2001 our
largest charitable gift might have been
two hundred and fifty dollars and all of
a sudden we were propelled into a new
world and didn't really have a lot of
chance no one told us what to expect we
weren't trained for that
and you realize how many new friends you
can establish when they know that
there's something that you can make
donations to their favorite causes so it
was a it was overwhelming I think we we
knew a course that we wanted to make we
experimented quite a bit which I hope we
have a chance to talk about because
we've learned a lot over these 10 or 11
years